thanks for introduction and thanks for
allowing me to speak here so today I'm
going to talk about fast permutation
healthy testing this is a joint work
with Jacob box at Stanford so I'll let P
be a property which you can consider as
a collection of objects satisfying this
property we want to be able to
distinguish quickly between the objects
satisfying this property or it is far
away from this property and if the
object is in between them we don't
really care about the output so some
examples can be that's a graph contain
our cycles or is a functional linear
function or that's there a permutation
contain no increasing subsequence of
length n so you can consider for now
permutation for example is the rankings
of a bunch of websites so traditionally
in the article computer science with the
input size n a polynomial running
polynomial running time function is
algorithm is considered a fast but
improperly testing so for example if
your input is a graph or the rankings of
many websites the input size is enormous
so even a quadratic tester is going to
be slow so we want to be able to make a
decision by curing a very small portion
of the input so an algorithm does that
is called a property tester and this is
going to be a randomized algorithm and
is used to test the membership of a
collection so it so in the talk when I
say something satisfy this property is
the equivalent to say the object is in
this property the tester is called one
sided for some property P is such that
is able two distinct very good decision
in two cases so the first case is when
this object has this property that we
want the tester to output the object if
this has this property and the other
extreme cases when the object is
absolute far from satisfying this
property under some metrics then we want
with decent probability we can output
the object
not in this property so here the
probability to thurs is somehow
artificial we can change that number to
anything greater than a half by
repeating this process multiple times so
another tester will usually consider is
called two-sided so this is the tester
such that in both cases it can it will
output with probability at least to
third so the two-sided tester is weaker
than a one-sided tester because in the
first case when the object has this
property we also allow you to have
mistake and the goal is we want to know
whether there exists a tester with
constant Curie complexity so here the
concept means it shouldn't depend on the
input size and it can only depend on
epsilon and the property we further even
well the constant Curie complexity to be
small in 1 over Epsilon so some
polynomial you want not a one over
absolutely would be great a very
beautiful and nice result in this
general result in this field is done by
Alan inicia PIRA in 2006 so they show
for any hereditary property p which is a
general property for graphs there exists
a one-sided tester so the only allow
mistake in when the graph is far away
from this property and so this property
and they show this proper this tester
has constant Curie complexity and the
metric they use is the added distance
which is a very natural metric for
graphs so the other distance is the
fraction of address you have to change
add or delete in order to change from
one graph to the other and a hereditary
crap property is such that if a large
graph is in this property then any of
this induced sub graph of the hostas
property their tester is a very natural
tester so you think uniformly at random
and vertices from this graph and you
consider the induced sub graph on these
vertices and if this induced sub graph
has this property than your output the
graph has this
property and if this induced graph
doesn't have this property than you then
the test your should output it doesn't
have this property so it's also easy to
see that from this tester when the large
graph the original input has this
property because of hereditary because
the property is hereditary then the
Indian sub graph this also also has this
property so this tester is at least one
sided and they by the definition of the
tester when the graph is absolute far
away from this property entered at a
distance then with high probability this
with this on probability the Indian sub
graph should not be in this property so
we can also translate into this the
corollary here so when the graph is
absolute far from this property then at
least two third of the induced sub graph
will not having this will not have this
property there proof gives an upper
bound on the Curie complexity which is
at least was earth what balls are type
in 10 reps oil so if you consider tower
function as a as 2 2 2 2 2 2 2 with the
layers of juices and the vaulted
hidebound is going to be iterating the
tower function n times and this this one
is later improved by Colin and Fox treat
our type for typical properties so in
fact weak or no bound is a common
drawback for the test for general
property testings in this area because
usually regularity method is used which
will lead to a very large bound or
compactness argument is used in New each
case no such no explicit found is given
so the major open question for testing
general properties in the for general
for testing general property is that
whether we can find a better theory
complexity in 1 over epsilon and many
long-standing open problems in many
long-standing problems in number theory
increment oryx are related to getting
better bound for property testing
and we studied this by so we study this
question for testing hereditary
permutation properties which is a
general property for permutations which
I will define later and in general we
show there exists testers with constant
kiri complexity not depending on the
length of the permutation it only
depends on the property and the constant
kiri complexity is polynomially in one
over epsilon so before I go into the
literature review and and the formal
statement of the theorems let me first
define what is a permutation and sub
permutations because this is going to be
used for wait for the later talk so
throughout this talk is useful to
consider permutations as represented in
unit squares if a permutation half
length n we usually consider is cutting
the unit square into n concrete columns
and rows such that each column and intro
has exactly one dot and we read a
permutation from left to right so for
example that the left graph shows the
representation of permutation four to
six five three one so you just read the
value of the dot from left to right a
sub permutation is such that you from
the original permutation you pick a
subset of the dots and only consider the
relative orders of those thoughts and
this is this gives as a sub permutation
so for example if you choose the three
red dots over here then their relative
order is 132 and so we say 132 is a sub
permutation of the primitives on the
left
um a hereditary permutation property is
similar to her edge of a graph property
so it says if a big permutation is in
this property then any of the oldest sub
permutation should also be in this
property so for example p being the set
of permutation avoiding 132 is going to
be hereditary because if the large
permutation is avoiding 132 as a sub
permutation then any of the sub
permutation of the big permutation
should also avoid the pattern 132 and
this is a graph which this is a
permutation here is here so this is a
permutation that it's not in this
property because it has a sub
permutation nope the pattern 132 and a
very simple observation is for any
proper property P because its proper so
it must at least avoid some permutation
as supplementation and if the property P
avoids Sigma as a supplementation then
if we know a permutation pi contains
Sigma as a pattern then pi should not be
in this property so that's how so that's
why in later is very useful to consider
a pattern avoidance for permutations
okay so since we need to do a randomized
testers so it's also useful to so we
should define what metrics were using in
order to say a permutation is absolute
far from the property so unlike grabs
where there's the natural distance for
permutations there are several different
metrics that arise commonly in
statistics and rankings and and we study
the property testing with respect to
those metrics so the first one I'm going
to introduce is called the rectangular
distance it's also called a cut the sims
so ignore the formula for now I'm going
to explain this by the picture so you
remember we can represent permutations
as a bunch of dolls in unit squares so
here we have two permutations the red
one and the blue one you draw a
rectangle a geometric rectangle in this
unit Square and you cut so for example
in this one there are four blue dots and
to read dolls in this rectangle
so that this criticism is too we so that
rectangular distances defines us the
largest discrepancy among oh the
rectangular can have on this in this
rectangle and recall that the largest
discrepancy at most n because they are
only n points so we can normalize it by
1 over N in this formula so that the
metric is the distances between 0 and 1
and this rectangular distance is analog
to the grab cut distance which is
commonly used in week regularity lemma
graph approximation algorithms and is
also useful for accounting sub graphs
and similarly it also hosts for
permutations so if two permutations are
various as distance mall in cut distance
then almost Oda counting's then the
accounting for supper mutations in these
two permutations are about the same
another commonly use metric is called
earthmovers distance so the name kind of
suggests what this metric means again we
have two permutations that one and the
blue one the earthmovers distance is the
minimum distance i have to move in order
to make move the in order to move in
order to make the blue permutation go
through the wrapper imitation what does
that mean is you find a matching between
the two permutations and we have to move
the blue dots along those bars in of the
matching to go to the red dots and the
earthmovers distance is defined
afternoon before normalizing the minimum
distance I have to move among other the
optimal matching so the mathematical
formula is like this so theta is going
to a bike action between the two
permutations which gives the matching
and so I minus theta I is going to be
the horizontal distance each doll is
moving along the bars and this term is
going to be the vertical distance each
stop has to move along along the bars
and we are minimizing oh the other
matching theta and the normalization
factor here is under a 1 over interest
too so that the distance is between 0
and 1
a thirdly commonly used metric is called
the candles tell distance leaves
commonly used in rankings so this is
defined as the normal the minimum the
normalized minimum number of adjacent
transpositions which means you are
allowed to swapping elements into
adjacent columns so the minimum such
adjacent transpositions you need to do
in order to turn the first permutation
into second permutation so the number of
adjacent transpositions you have to do
to turn one permutation into identity
permutation is going to be the number of
inversions in that permutation so I
introduced three matrix the rectangular
one door through words distance and in
candles out distance and their relations
is as follows so the rectangular
distance is equivalent to earth movers
distance up to polynomial change and
both of these matrix are weaker than
Kendall's tau distance in a sense that
if Kendall's tau distance is small then
the first two distances are small so we
can also sort of see it by their
definition so both rectangular distance
and earthmovers distance you can sort of
move the points both horizontally and
vertically but for Kendall's tau
distance is less geometric because you
are not allowed really to move the
points horizontally you're only allowed
to swapping the columns and another way
to see it is you given two random
permutations of length n then the
earthmovers distance is almost with high
probabilities are the earthmovers
distance between the two random
permutations is little one while the
candles child distance is theta one so
kennesaw distance this is strongest so
what does it mean after we translate
into tester so if I can give you a
tester with respect to the candles tell
distance then this tester is naturally
going to be a tester for the weaker
metrics this is because if my
permutation is far away under the even
weaker matrix then the distance between
the permutation of the property is even
going to be a larger ended a stronger
stronger magic candles total distance
but usually if we are testing with
respect to the weaker
ettrick we can get a better kiri
complexity balance so now here I'm going
to do some literal literature review for
testing permutations so one of the first
nice results in this area is done by
Copa Copa & Co hayakawa maria and sam
pyro in 2012 so they proved that there
exists a one-sided tester with respect
to the rectangular distance and they are
using compactness argument so it won't
yield any explicit bound but I have to
say so for their paper they are using
the very natural tester as well so pick
a random sub permutation and see whether
that supplementation has this property
or not and they further conjectured
weather so the further conjecture that
with respect to the Kendall's tau
distance this natural tester will give a
one-sided is going to be a one-sided
tester and this is confirmed in 2014 by
claiming show and crawl they they they
proved that with respect to the stronger
metric the candles tell distance the
natural tester picking a random sub
permutation to see whether it is is
probably or not is going to be a
one-sided tester with kyra complexity so
but they are bound is is is a bit weak
so for testing even when the preferred
for testing even Sigma avoidance they
they are bound will be ackerman type in
one over epsilon and we improved it
bound with respect to the candle so
distance oh and it gives a the Curie
complexity be polynomially in 1 over
epsilon for testing Sigma avoidance and
by using the same natural tester and we
come up with some other tester and which
will give better bound with respect to
the rectangular distance and it's almost
quadratic in 1 over epsilon with respect
to rectangular distance but I have to
say like this bound is so this tester is
going to be two-sided if we allow it to
be one-sided then the bound is going to
be worse but for typical properties is
still going through polynomial
so here is the formal statement of the
main theorem so a given P to be any
property that four bits Sigma as supper
mutation then there exists a one-sided
tester with Curie complexity polynomial
in one over epsilon with respect to the
Kendall's tau distance the tester we use
is the same as the tester as the
previous work is a natural tester so you
uniformly random sample a sub
permutation of size M from high so what
does it mean is if pi has length n so
you choose uniformly at random an M
subset of from 1 to N and you look at
the induced sub permutation on that set
and for this sub permutation we so if
this a permutation is in the property we
output it is in this property and if
it's not in this property we don'twe
output the original permutation it's not
in this property so again is easy to see
that when the perimeter original
permutation is in this property by
hereditary then the sub permutation is
going to be in this property and when
the permutation is not in this is far
from this property then with this
improbability the sample sub permutation
is not going to be in this property so
the corollary becomes at least 1 minus
absolute fraction of the supper mutation
of that size will contain a copy of the
pattern that I'm trying to avoid and
this bound is the same as the security
complexity in the theorem is going to be
polynomial in 1 over epsilon and the
exponent or the degree of this
polynomial is double exponential so this
degree the double exponential comes from
the Marco starter theorem and wheels so
for this proof a also we use both at
Marcos charter theorem and cake very
cutting cake fair cutting lemmas and
some other common Toric's results so
there's this previous quite involved and
I'm not going to touch the proof of this
main theorem so for this talk I'm going
to give some proof sketch for a much
simpler theorem
which is testing with respect to the
weaker matrix the earthmovers distance
so recall of earthmovers distance is you
find a matching between the two
permutations and see how far you have to
move from the blooper matrix into the
rat permutation and the theorem we're
going to give some proof idea for in
this talk is given in this statement so
let P be any hereditary property and we
can show there exists a two-sided tester
with respect to the earthmovers distance
and the Curie complexity is almost
quadratic up to log factor and
surprisingly this Curie complexity is
independent from the property and also
our theorem has is only useful when
testing sufficiently large permutations
do these things apply to a realization
of permutation such as don't lose
stochastic matrices uh I think so yes
thanks for the question okay um but then
so this found is now the optimal we can
get we can also improve the balance so
by removing the log factor so we can
remove the log factor by doing some more
careful analysis of of the proof and we
can further improve this bound to almost
linear oh absolutely no minus one log
square Absalom war two and but what this
found is going to be depending on P so
to improve from the quadratic bound to
the almost linear bound we have to use a
marker starter theorem again okay so
before formally describing a tester
because we're not using the natural
tester for this proof have to define
something called a blow-up of a
permutation so I guess many audience
have already familiar with the blow up
for graphs so for permutation is
something similar we are given a small
permutation say alpha equals 24 31 which
is the rep permutation over here the
blow-up is such that each point blows up
into a cluster of a classroom points
such that oh those clusters
form the shape of 24 31 so the four
rectangle rectangle is here form the
shape 24 31 and those rectangles are
destroying horizontally and vertically
we don't really care about relative
orders of the points within each block
so the main idea is the small
permutation blow us up into some
rectangle so some collection of
rectangles which form the same shape and
this is also called a block
decompositions where the blocks form the
shape of the original small permutation
and a que blow-up is such that each
block contains exactly K points so it's
kind of a eco blowing up so here is our
tester so is this given the original
permutation we sample a sub permutation
of plants and from a uniformly at random
we output the original permutation
satisfies this property if and only if
for any integer K there there exists one
k blow-up of the samples of permutation
that satisfies this property so for okay
no matter how large a blow-up we are
required you can find a blow-up that is
in this property so capable of again is
each block contains exactly K points
well that's this tester for now sounds
very scary because we are we have to
check for anything okay but in fact this
is a finite check is that it rises to
check up to some sudden k the reasons
the reason is simple but you probably
still requires I'm thinking so we can
show for any lens as the the largest k
we need to check is some blow up
parameter KPS depending on the property
and this parameter the blow-up Constance
is such that for any permutation of lens
s if there is a KPS blow-up of this
permutation in this property then for
any larger k there is going to be a que
blow-up of the permitted of the
supplementation in this property in
other words so KPS can be considered as
the size of
so the maximum over all permutations of
length s and minimum counter-examples
such that the blow-up is not in this
property so if you buy the fact that
such a blow-up constant exists then the
test or bob is going to translate into
this for the disk tester which sounds a
lot more friendly is this given a
permutation of length n and sample pi
primer plant em from PI uniform at
random then we can output pi is in this
property if and only if there exists a
KPM blow-up of the sample
supplementation in this property and
will by the fact that this is a finite
check because you want your only
checking for a certain size of blowing
up and in the worst thing you can do is
or the most trivial thing to do is to
check any single blowing up of this size
so it usually is it's hard to determine
the cause the blowing up constant
exactly but there are some there are
some facts about the diss constants
which gave us some dis and upper bound
okay so first so if translated theorem
into the corollary it is similar as
before given a corridor in the structure
of the permutations it says if a
permutation is absolute far from the
property entered earthmovers distance
then Ali is 1 minus Absalom fraction of
the summer sub permutations of size n
are such that 0 there KPM blow-up are
not going to be in this property ok so
some examples of permutations and
they're blowing ups in or not in the
property so for example we consider p as
the set of all permutations avoiding the
pattern 123 as a sub permutation and
assuming our sample permutation is just
one through the very simple one like
this one a clipless a weaker we all go
show for NE kiya dere's a blow-up of
this permutation that is not in this
property which means the blowing up is
not going to contain a pattern 1 2 3 so
the easy thing we can do is in
two blocks which the two blocks from the
table want you we feel in monotone
decreasing for the sub permutations and
it is easy to see that this permutation
is not going to contain a pattern 1 2 3
because i cannot find an increasing
sequence of length 3 in this blowing up
so this is a very simple and intuitive
example but for some permutations and
other properties the bound is going to
be slightly more trickier as i lay
trickier so for example if p is going to
be the set of permutations avoiding two
patterns 15 2 for 2 3 4 & 1 5 4 3 2 is a
simple exercise to see if your sample
permutation is 132 then for any k less
equal to four you can find a que blow-up
of pi prime that avoids both of the two
patterns but if I tell you k equals 25 k
equal to five then all the five blow-ups
of the supplementation is going to avoid
is going to contain at least one of
these two patterns by arash surgeries at
theorem okay so I promise you that
there's some simple bound for the
blowout parameters so for typical
property P such that the property P is
the set of permutations only avoiding a
finite number of permutations of
supplementation's then this constant is
going to be within this block comes in
KP is going to be bounded by our
constant which only depending on the
length of the minimum permutations you
are avoiding so this is not a very easy
fact so I can so so basically it says if
we only allow monotone so if so it says
like if we only allow monotone
increasing or decreasing feelings in
each box in the blow-up then as long as
the block size is at least the largest
length of the permutations you are
avoiding then then if a permutation then
if any k permutation is not in this
property than the side length of Sigma
the length of the Sigma is going to be
enough
and by art of Sakura theorem you know if
I have a if I have a sequence of our
permutations of length K minus 1 square
plus 1 then there must exist an
increasing or decreasing sequence of
length K so that's how this bunk comes
from so this is a nice one so if we are
lazy of checking exactly what is K p.m.
that we can simply use this bound and
this found that has nothing to do with
the length of the original permutation n
but for some other properties the bound
is even better so for ppl permutations
avoiding a set of twin free permutations
at supplementation's then the blow-up
constant is exactly one so at winfrey
permutation means there are not two
points in the permutation that are in
adjacent columns and rows so the
relative order of these two points to
all the rest points are the same so
that's why they are called twins is okay
um so if kpu equals to 1 then pastor it
basically says if there exists a capable
up of the supper mutation in p for any k
this is equivalent to say the sub
permutation itself is in this property
which means well in the in a very nice
case 1 KP equal to 1 we don't have to
check a blow-up of the sample
supplementation it becomes a natural
tester that we just need to see whether
the supplementation itself the sample
itself is imp you or not so the
corollary becomes assuming we are given
the property that it avoids a set of
twin free permutations of sub
permutations which happens very often
then if pi is absolute far away from p
then at least one minus absolute
fraction of the sub permutations of size
M is not going to be in this property so
in this in this verse yeah Tokyo being
free is not hereditary right
so so so is avoiding a set up between
free permutations so it'll voice your
voice i setup supplementation's and
those sub permutations are twin free
yeah yeah it's a bit harder ok thanks ok
so now i'm going to give some proof idea
of the main theorem so remember our task
is to say if pi is in bit this property
or is absolute far away with respect to
the earth morris distance then our
randomized tester should make pretty
good decision about whether the original
permutation is in this property or not
and our tester is we output pies in P if
and only if there's a typo okay if and
only if for any K there is a que blow-up
of the sample in this property which is
equivalent to say if and only if there
is a KPM blow-up of the sample pi prime
in this property so we need to check two
cases so the first case which is
relatively easier case is when the
permutations in this property so one
this probably from a difference in this
property with what our tester to output
with decent probability that the pious
in this property so a key observation
for this part of the proof is that when
the original permutation is large enough
then pi typically contains a large
blow-up of the Sun post a permutation so
this observation has nothing to do with
pie in this property or not so this is a
general observation house for any large
permutations and a sub permutations so
if we buy this fact so if we agree on
this observation then what does it mean
it means if my original permutations in
this property them by since the property
is hereditary then this large flow up of
the sample is going to be in this
property and our tester will output pie
is in this property because this large
blow-up of the sample is in this
property by the description of the
tester so I'm going to give some
intuition why this observation is true
so we represent the
huge permutation in unit square and the
thoughts including the black ones and
red ones are all parts of the
permutation and the red triangles are
going to be the sample points so if we
look at this representation globally
then we can see there are some
relatively dense regions and some
relatively sparse regions and for and it
is very likely when the primitive
original permutation is large almost so
all the sample points are come from the
dense regions and no point no sample
points come from the sparse regions and
so in this case so for example we have
for dense regions the green rectangles
over here and all the sample points come
from the dense regions and and for each
of the sample because it lies in some
very dense regions so there are lots of
other points in the original permutation
that are around this sample points so
you can sort of imagine growing some
neighborhood from each of the sample
points and each of the sample points
grow into some small neighborhoods and
those small neighborhoods are destroying
horizontally and vertically and so they
form the shape of the samples the
supplementation from the sample and that
blowing a blow-up is going to be in the
original permutation so that provides
some intuition about why when the
original provocation is large it
typically contains a large blow-up of
the sample sub permutation so the
slightly harder so the harder cases in
in the second case so we want to show
when the earthmovers distance between
the permutation and property is large
with respect to the earthmovers distance
then typically our tester will output
the permutation it's not in this
property so again our tester is so we
randoms new uniform I random sample was
a permutation from this property from
this permutation and you output the
permutations in this property if and
only if for any K there exists a cape
low up of this sample supplementation in
this property a key lemma says typically
we can construct a blow-up of the sample
permutation that is close to the
original permutation
under earthmover systems again this key
Lama has nothing to do with a pie in
this property or not so this is also a
general lemma that holds for all
permutations and there are typical
samples so one as a typical I mean with
high probability the thing will happen
and if we agree on this fact then we can
prove by contradiction to show why our
tester works well in the case at one
path in the case that pie is far away
from this property so suppose the tester
make a mistake and it outputs pious in
this property then from the description
of the tester it will all put pies in
this property if only if and only if all
the large pool there always exists large
blocks of the sample permutation that is
MP and I all made the so I kind of just
use the fact that oh the blow-ups are of
the sample permutation are close to each
other then this means this large blow up
we construct from the key lemma is going
to be close to the property P but then
because this blow-up we construct is
also close to the original permutation
it means pi the original permutation
pipe itself is going to be close to the
permutation and this gives us a
contradiction because in this case we
already assume that distance between pi
and the property is very large so the
main thing for this case is to see how
to construct a blow-up of the sample
permutation the red small permutation
that is close to the original
fermentation pipe so look at those
pictures or how do we how can we move
the point black points such that they so
such that the new permutation looks like
the blow-up of the sample protection
so there is also some very intuitive way
of doing this so if we want to move the
original permutation to to mimic a
blow-up of the sample the first thing
comes to mind is we just move all the
points in a permutation to the closest
sample point it is too so so here I the
dashed lines indicate which sample play
is closest to that point in this
fermentation and then you just move all
those points to those sample points so
now I have four clusters of points and
those clusters basically a look at Shea
look like the shape of the original
samples of permutation and this sort of
already becomes up blowing up because I
have four clusters of points which from
the shape of the sample fermentation but
we are not done yet because we need to
obtain a permutation and for permutation
we need each column and each row in its
congruent Colin Munro has exactly one
point but here I kind of squeeze
everything into one point for each of
the cluster but it doesn't really matter
too much so we can sort of move each
cluster a little bit and it moves of
points within each clusters a little bit
so that this guy's becomes a permutation
and this is a blowing up and so this is
going to be the blow-up we construct and
the goal is to show the original
permutation on the leftmost picture is
closed in distance to the final
permutation we construct there are 22
they are in both of the steps we have
moved the permutations of it so the
first one is in step one when we move
all the points to the closest simple
point and the second step when we when
we kind of move locally those points to
in order to obtain a permutation well if
the good news is the the total distance
I moved in the second step is not very
large compared to the distance I moved
in the first step so in fact the total
distance I moved in the in the second
Sabitha is within constant factor of the
total distance I moved in the first
so by triangulating quality we just need
to bound the total distance I move in
the first step in order to show the
distance between the original
permutation and the final blow up i
construct is going to be small so I want
to bound the total distance I move in
the first step which is how many what
was the distance I move so that each
point goes to the closest sample point
and this is done by dyadic partition
which is a commonly used technique in
computer science theoretical computer
science so a dyadic partition we say a
square stance if it contains at least a
quadratic in absolute number of points
of the original permutation so here our
definition of tens is slightly unusual
because our definition of tens has
nothing to do with the area of the
rectangle so we only count the absolute
number of points in that rectangle and
the original unit square is going to be
tensed because it has n points since it
contains all the points in a permutation
so the original unit square is going to
be dense so the dense core splits into
four squares so each time I have a 10
square is split into four congruent
squares and for the concurrent squares
of Alice for smaller squares wheels we
again how the number of points of the
original fermentation in those squares
and there are two things can happen so
the small one case is the small permit
the small square becomes dense where the
small square become sparse so if the
small square is sparse then it stays far
so it doesn't move anymore so it becomes
freezed but if the square is stands it
continued splitting so we continue
splitting all the ten squares into come
grand sub squares and the whole
procedure stops if all the scores become
sparse in which case I cannot do any
movement any more or when the smaller
square is of sight lines linear in
Absalom so some small constant times
Absalom so if we imagine the whole
dyadic procedure we can see towards the
very end the unit square got the part
turn into spar squares of different
sizes and some small 10 squares and all
those 10 squares have site land exactly
action / 16 so it kind of becomes a
picture look like this so we won't you
found it so again we want to remember we
want to burn the total distance oh okay
before that still recall or 10 square
contains at least absolute square times
n over 4 points of the original
permutation so by a Union bound the
probability that some 10 square contains
no sample point which is the event we
don't want to happen is going to be by
the Union bound the total number of 10
squares multiplied by the probability
that the specific 10 square doesn't
contain any sample point and since our
dense core contains at least Absalom
square and points up the permutation the
probability that none of the sample
points hits this 10 square is going to
be 1 minus the number of points in this
permutation in this square and to the
power of the sample because all the
samples are chosen you need from
independently and if we work this math
Alice you can see this is founded by
Absalom by our choice of em the the Kira
complexity and therefore we just show
that the probability that sound n square
contains no sample point is bounded
above by Absalom so we can conditional
condition on this event and assume all
the scores once danced contain nose
contact will contain some sample point
and now we are ready to bound the total
distance we move which is the total
distance each point in the original
primatech removed through it close a
sample point so there are two cases
again we need to consider so the first
case is we count the total distance the
points in the 10 square moved so in this
example because we are already under the
condition that oh the den squares
contain some sample point so if a point
is already in a 10 square then we know
the closest sample point it moves you is
bounded above by the distance this is to
the
sample point in that then square itself
and already know the ten squares are
very small in this island which is
epsilon over 16 then a todo el want
distance though the points in the ten
squares move is almost twice the site
length of the smallest n square and the
total so so the distance it moves a
small and so and we can be lazy n and
bound the maximum number of such points
which is at most n because i only have n
points in this permutation the second
case is we have to consider two points
from sparse squares of side length 2 to
the minus I and whole and and how much
what's the distance such a point will
move so remember we render the condition
that each square Winston's will contain
some sample point so if this square is
sparse it means it must comes from
splitting off at n square which is this
square so in the previous step this
square is its dense and then therefore
you can split into four squares and in
this square becomes then it becomes
sparse and then we are another condition
that this square contains some sample
points say for example here so the total
distance this point moves in a most
twice this island of of this square
which is 2 times 2 to the minus I minus
1 so that this sense each point move is
not too small but the number of such
points is small because oh because this
is appointing a sparse square which
doesn't contain too many points and the
number of such point is that most 2222 I
which is the number of sparse scores of
sight lines through to de- I did the
upper bound on that and each of such
scores containing at most these many
points because the square is is sparse
so the total distance we move it is by
adding up these two cases together so is
some geometric series and then and after
you do this you can see the computation
comes up easily the total distance we
move as a mouse Absalon and over four so
it kind of prove some proof
to show that the original permutation is
close to a blow-up of the sample
permutation so the conclusion is for
testing hereditary permuted a current
agent property we have some we have some
testers one with respect to the candles
how distance the Curie complexity is
polynomially in one over epsilon with
the degree is sort of the constant
coming out from Marcus Carter theorem
and this is for testing p being Sigma
voiding and the polynomial bound can be
generalized for testing some other
typical properties and with respect to
the weaker matrix which is the
earthmovers seasons and rectangular
distance we are able to obtain a
polynomial bound for two-sided testers
with the degrees with the degrees is
very small one or two or four and we and
even there exists universal balance and
now depending on the properties and for
one sided testers the Curie complexity
is style it worse because that will
depend on the the blowout parameter I
just described in this talk okay so
there are some open questions so a first
question we have are interested in this
for the earth-moon system so for the two
bounds depending on the property can we
actually remove the log factor and the
second second open question is can we
prove some quadratic bound of for
testing with respect to the rectangular
distance so here we obtain this bound is
because the earthmover distance is
equivalent to rectangular distance
because earthmovers is easier to work
with through testing with respected or
rectangular distance we first translate
to testing with respect to earth movers
distance and by the equivalence of the
two matrix we we obtain the bound for
the rectangular distance so the open
question becomes can we work directly
with the direction your distance that
now paying a better round and another
question is its quadratic belt actually
a lower bound for testing with respect
to the rectangular distance and can we
use similar methods to approximate the
rectangular distance between two
permutation
up to some additive arrows oh yeah
that's all for my talk today thank you
[Applause]
and this is promised at kop for
hereditary hereditary properties always
computable or do you have examples where
it's not so we have some upper bound for
it I don't know whether there's a very
efficient way of checking it for any
problem I'll speak out nutty as please
so my question was whether it's a
decidable to calculate or is it
computable to calculate this parameter k
of p god guess not probably not for
simple ones if it really so if it's a
fine set of avoiding and you can
determine it but i would expect like the
leg in the ground in the glass case they
would expect it to be like that
so yo method is so general so maybe it
can be used to the proof similar results
and exposing our distance for higher
dimensional permutation I have nothing
square because it seems that the to do
everything here should work and that
there is some sort of divergence of
Syria since the other so have you tried
it I haven't that's also were
interesting direction yeah thank you for
putting it out
[Applause]